[Music]  welcome to the city of dakota  the big bang protests changed everything  including me  i'm static a few of us survived and got  these powers  now i can control electricity i'm going  to fight to make a difference  my life changed when i met a 200 year  old super powered alien  i'm raquel irvin i asked him if he could  get rid of the drug dealers and save our  city  i'm rocket and he's icon now he gave me  this power belt  and made me his apartment you don't need  powers to fight for justice if you've  got the right hardware  i invented high-tech armor and next  level weapons to even the playing field  with the corrupt powers of this world  the big shots think they can push us all  around  well just try pushing me  together together together we'll get  justice for those who can't stand up for  themselves  it'll be a milestone  you